former congresswoman tulsi gabriel
congresswoman you don't agree with
everything i say i i think i can say
that with a certain degree of cert with
a high degree of certainty
you're laughing go ahead laugh
i agree
all right but but you do believe
in free speech you do believe in open
debate
not many democrats will come on a
program like this why won't they come
that's a good question for them i can
tell you why i come is because i do
believe very much in free speech civil
discourse and dialogue this is what is
at the heart of our democracy where the
american people have the opportunity to
gather information
have debate have dialogue maybe
sometimes fiery sometimes calm but then
really come to our own conclusions as
the american people and then choose
leaders who we believe will reflect
those views and who will uphold our
constitution and maintain
that freedom sean and that's what's so
dangerous about all these different
things that these these different things
that we're seeing here whether it's with
joe rogan or many of the other people
who are facing this kind of censorship
and silencing that's coming from the
power elite up on high
who decide okay here's the message
here's the propaganda that we want to
put out in the country that we want to
be able to control they use their
their uh propagandists within the
mainstream media news to do their work
and they want to make sure people
swallow whatever it is they're pushing
out and if you don't if you disagree or
dare to question or bring a different
perspective or a different view then
they have their tactics to either
try to censor or silence you or
discredit you smear your character so
that when you speak they've already
they've already created this suspicion
in people's minds like hey we can't
trust whatever that person says and that
prevents them from having to actually
debate
on the issues having to deal with the
substance of the issues that affect the
american people in our country
i think that's why my audience does have
a deep respect for you i've gotten we
get numerous comments whenever you're on
the program to me it's very simple
we we
give lip service to the word freedom
right there's nobody i can't force i
wish i could actually but i can't force
people to watch this show a full hour
every night i wish they would i hope
they will i try to put on a good show so
they speaking of freedom and you know
all i ask is three hours a day on radio
one hour at night on tv
um
but
why is it now become like an alien
concept this thing called freedom nobody
forces anybody to watch anything or
listen to anything and there are more
choices out there than we've ever had
before
why don't they use their freedom not to
watch what they don't like or what they
disagree with
yeah exactly and i think that's what is
personally so troubling to me about
these threats and attacks on our
freedoms that are rooted in our
constitution that are rooted in our
identity as americans
freedom needs to mean something to us
all for me i took an oath as a soldier
and as a member of congress to uphold
and defend our constitution and so when
i talk about the defense of free speech
whether i agree with what you're saying
or not that's something i have committed
to giving my life to doing each of us as
americans have to understand and our own
responsibility to stand up and protect
that freedom in our own way and reject
this censorship and just remind people
what this is all about and how if we
allow these threats to continue and this
censorship to continue the the power
elite to spread their own controlling
propaganda we will lose who we are as a
country we will no longer have this
democratic republic we will have a
dictatorship that is controlling what
people are allowed to hear what we're
allowed to see and what we're allowed to
say and we will be america no longer
i'll tell you what the next time you're
on you can get asked me any question on
any topic you disagree with me on and
i'll let and don't tell me ahead of time
obviously and we'll give you a chance to
because there are things we disagree on
but we appreciate you being with us
congresswoman as always thank you thanks
john hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else